so this is just an example from one of
my recent games from the Sinquefield cup
against against Westley so in this game
I'd sacrifice the pawn in their opening
I'd gained really a good compensation
with stronger minor pieces and
eventually a bit of a bind on the
kingside can now see that my very
advanced pawn on h6 which is eventually
what won me the game it's very dangerous
if is pawn drops at any time that will
be absolutely disastrous so we'll have
he'll have long-term problems here in
spite of the fact that he was just
recently upon up in this position I have
to be honest like I had for a couple of
move kind of panicked because I had seen
that he could pin pin my queen
by playing Queen to b7 and now for a
long time I didn't I didn't know what to
do and I was just sitting there really
shaken because I thought I'd turned a
very good position into a losing one and
I did but at the same time it felt like
my position should still be very good so
there had to be something and while he
was thinking for for me a surprisingly
long time it just occurred to me that
the solution is extremely simple and I'm
sure that many of you will find the
right solution in a in a very short time
but this just goes to show that in in in
a game it is sometimes more more
difficult when you're not looking in
that in the right place I was looking at
all sorts of different possibilities
pushing the pawn but then he can move
his rook to
- to see seven attacking the night once
again and I'm in big trouble or or to
even possibilities like c3b take c3b for
trying to support the night on next move
and if we should be four then king c2
trying to get the rook to - to be one
but but of course as many of you have
seen by now
the solution is much simpler than that
just take take the bishop on takes and
checkmate so pretty simple to move
combination but just goes to show if
you're not working looking in the right
place then you might never find it and
who knows if he had made his move
instantly instead of taking some time
when I eventually found the combination
then I might have been in trouble